اعلنا الجيش الكوري والجنوبي وان كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت السبت بعد صواريخ بالستيه
قصيره المدى ضمن تصعيد تجاربها الشرقيه
هذا الاسبوع
وتتزمن هذه الخطوه مع ختام واشنطن وسور
منورات استمرت سته ايام شاركت فيها قاذفات
ونستراتيجيه من طراز بي وان بي كما تزامنت
مع قسمات في مجلس الامن بشان الموقف من
التجارب الصاروخيه لكوريا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا لنا
في نقاشه مسارات الثلاث ماذا
على تكثيف اطلاق صواريخ البالستيه في هذا
التوقيت وما نجاحه الخطوات التي تتخذها
السوق وحلفائها لمواجهه هذا الوضع وما هي
المالاته المحتمله للتوتر الراهن في شبه
جزيره الكوريه في ضوء تزامنه مع الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا والتصعيد بين الصين
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نفهم انقسام مجلس
الامن بشان الموقف من كوريا الشماليه واي
خيارات تتركها هذه الانقسامات لاداره
بايضا للتعامل مع بيونغ في المرحله
المقبله
[موسيقى]
بحسب معلنه الجيش الكوري الجنوبيه
اطلقت يوم
السبتيه قصيره المدى باتجاه البحر عمليه
تاتي ضمن
تجارب الصاروخيه هذا الاسبوع حيث اطلقت
عددا قياسيا من الصواريخ البالستيه قصيره
المدى شملت يوم الاربعاء والخميس الماضيين
صاروخا باريسيا عابرا للقارات
وصاروخا سقط قرب المياه الاقليميه الكوريه
الجنوبيه في حادثه هي الاولى منذ انتهاء
الحرب بين الكوريتين قبل 70 عاما
التصعيد في شبه الجزيره الكوريه شامله
ايضا التدريبات الجويه المشتركه بين
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه التي
عرفت باسم العاصفه اليقظه استمرت سته ايام
تدريباته العاصفه ليقظه اليقظه التي
وصفتها بيوم بيان بانها استفزازيه وطلبت
واشنطن بوقتها شارك فيها نحو 200 40 طائره
عسكريه وقال ذا فتان استراتيجيه امريكيه
من طراز بي وان بي
وتعتبر هذه المره الاولى التي يتم فيها
استخدامه من طراز بي وان بي في تدريبات
المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه منذ عام 2017
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
ماثيو كرونك المستشار السابق في وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه ومن بيجين معنى فيكتور
جاو رئيس الجمعيه الصينيه
للدراسات الدوليه
من بيجين لماذا هذا الاصرار من كوريا
الشماليه على اطلاق الصواريخ بهذه الكثافه
في هذه المده القصيره
في شبه الجزيره امر مؤسف هذا يؤسف منا
فعلا ونحن ندعو كافه الاطراف المعنيه الى
خفض التصعيد ثانيا الناس في الغرب يبدو
انهم يركزون على
اطلاقه الصواريخ
المختلفه المدى ويعتبرون ان ذلك استفزازي
في الحقيقه
فان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت كل هذه الصواريخ
جدا على
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه غير المسبوقه
بين كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
وهذه المره حتى
استخدامات اذا عنا القاضي فات
الاستراتيجيه كوريا الشماليه تعتبر دوله
صغيره نسبيا اقتصادها ضعيف جدا
وجيشها لا يمكن مقارنته فعلا بالجيش
الامريكي اذن بالنسبه الى الجيش الامريكي
وحلفائه لا باس بجامعه كل هذه الاسلحه
المتقدمه والمتطوره فيها الطائرات
الاستراتيجيه والسفن الحربيه
والجيوش البريه وحتى القوى المارين كل ذلك
تعتبر كوريا الشماليه استفزازيا عادائا
كما لو اننا اشرفنا على حرب بين كوريا
الشماليه والولايات المتحده نتيجه لذلك
ليس هناك
امام كوريا الشماليه سواء الرد من خلال
اطلاق صواريخ مختلفه الفئات وهي اصلا
لديها رؤوس نوويه وبالتالي اذا كان هناك
اي سوء تقدير من اي من الجانبين فالامور
سوف تخرج عن السيطره وقد يحصل انفجار
النووي في هذه المنطقه
يقول انه مجرد رد على المناورات الامريكيه
الكوريه الجنوبيه اليابانيه التي تعتبر
ما الجديد في هذا التصعيد كوريا الشماليه
سبق واطلقت كل هذه الانواع من الصواريخ
تفضلها الدكتور
خطيرا ولكنني اعترض على ما تسبب بذلك
كوريا الشماليات تبني برنامج نوبيا خطيرا
يقدر بانه لديها 60 سلاحا نوويه وعدد من
الصواريخ البالستيه التي قد تصل الى
الولايات المتحده لديها صواريخ قصيره
المدى قد تصل الى القواعد الامريكيه في
المنطقه والى سيول بالنسبه الى المناورات
لم تبدا اليوم في الاسابيع الى 6 الاخيره
كوريا الشماليه قامت بالكثير من هذه
التجارب تريد ان تعزز قدراتها الصاروخيه
يريد صواريخ متحركه وصريخها من انواع
مختلفه ولهذا يجري هذه المناوره بالنسبه
الى التدريبات العسكريه العاديه التي
توجهها الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
فهي اعتياديه روتينيه لان دولتين حديثتان
يسمح لهما باجراء هذه التدريبات وبالتالي
تستخدم كوريا الشماليه هذه التدريبات كعذر
من اجل ان تعزيزا من برنامجها نووي وكذلك
قدراتها الصاروخيه وليس ردا على التدريبات
المختلف هذه المره اجابه السؤال هو ان
البرنامج الكوري الشماليه سامر في التطور
ويطرح تهديدا اكبر واكبر لسلام والامن
الدوليه يعني
سيد فيكتور جاو من بيجين ما هو موقف بيجين
قلت ان الوضع خطير وانه يمكن ان تنفجر حرب
نوويه في هذه المنطقه في اي لحظه وهو ليس
في مصلحه احد اين بيجين من ذلك
قد وصل رساله
مجلس الامن اعتمادا قرارات لادانه هذا
البرنامج وطلب خفض سعيد من قبل كوريا
الشماليه ولكن ايضا هناك سؤال مطروح لماذا
تطور كوريا الشماليه برنامج النوويه منذ
البدايه انا لا اعتقد انه يمكنه ان
تستاهلك هذه الاسلحه النوويه على شعبها هي
تريد ان تطور البرنامج النووي لهدفا واحدا
او احد الا وهو الحفاظ على سيادتها وسلامه
اراضيها كثير مواجهه هذا التعديدات
المتنميه من كوريا الجنوبيه
المتحده بتدريباتها
ومناوراتها العسك مشتركه
وبالاضافه الى اي تهديدات تريدها من
الجنوب كلنا نريد ان ننزع السلاح النووي
من هذه المنطقه لكن هذا يتعذر اذا لم
تتحاور كوريا الشماليه ومعلومات المتحده
في هذا السياق مع انني اعترض على الكثير
من مواقف الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب
ولكن على الاقل بدل جهودا للتفاعل مع
كوريا الشماليه التقى
الرئيس في عدد من السيارات حتى ان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق ترامب دخل كوريا الشماليه
وانا امل ان يقوم الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
بيضا واداراته
بعض بعض الجهود الملموسه في محاوله
لاعاده هذا الحوار مع كوريا الشماليه بدلا
من اعتماد موقف الضغط الاقصى لان كوريا
الشماليه كما نرى لا ترضخ ضغوطات
الامريكيه كلما زاد الضغط عليها زادت
مقاومتها كما نرى بام العين وبالتالي هذا
هو الوضع المؤسف الذي نشهده
راينا اننا شكوا على ان يشهد انفجار
النويا كلنا اذا حصل ذلك سنكون ضحايا بما
فيه الولايات المتحده لان البرنامج
الكوريه الشمالي يمكن ان يوصل صواريخه الى
الولايات المتحده والى عدد من القواعد
الامريكيه في اليابان في
السيول وغيرها اذا نحن نتحدث عن خطير
لنتعامل معه كما هو بدلا من ان نبدا ونتخ
بان الضغوطات القصوى من شانها ان ترضخ
وترك ع كوريا الشماليه
اوستن حذر من استخدام السلاح النووي ضد
الولايات المتحده او ضد حلفائها وان ثمن
له او الرد عليه سيكون انهاء نظام
بيونغيان
ما مصداقيه هذا التحذير اذا كانت الولايات
المتحده همم قادر على انهاء النظام بهذه
السهوله لماذا تنتظر حتى استخدام السلاح
النووي
تحديث
كبيره وموفقيه كبيره لا تقولها
بذلك قبل استخدام سلاح نووي لان هكذا حرب
سوف تؤدي الجميع وهدم لا تريد الولايات
المتحده لكن نستخدم كوريا الشماليه
المتحده اليدين وتنتظر استخدامه مره اخرى
حين ذلك سوف تنهي هذا النظام لديها القدره
لديها
الموارد والرئيس الكوري يدرك ذلك
اعرض ما قاله زميلي من بيجين
الولايات المتحده دائما دعت الى او
بالاحرى كوريا الشماليه
اراد دائما توحيد شبه الجزيره واعتقد ان
رئيس كوريا الشماليه ابني برنامج هناوي
ليس فقط يحيا نفسه بل ايضا لكي يؤمن نفسه
درعا يسمح له بالمدينه العدائيه ضد كوريا
الجنوبيه وهدم راينا هذا الاسبوع اما
بالنسبه الى الحلول فليس هناك حلول نافعه
جربنا كل شيء
اوباما وترامب كل هؤلاء الرؤساء جربوا
المفاوضات ولم تنجح
من المشكله هو عدم ممارسه من الضغوطات
الولايات المتحده فرضت عقوبات على كوريا
الشماليه لكن الصين تدعم والاقتصاد كوريا
الشمالي لو شاءت في الولايات المتحده ان
توقف البرنامج
في كوريا الشماليه
سيكون على كم يونج
بما يطلب منه لكن البرنامج النووي مستمر س
تسمح باستمراره ولا تضغط بما يكفي على
كوريا الشماليه
ما المصلحه الصينيه يا سيد فيكتور جاو في
عدم الضغط على كوريا الشماليه
المحترم من الولايات المتحده
الى مجلس الامن في العقوبات التي فرضها
مره اخرى على البرنامج النووي الكوري
الشمالي هذا امر غير مسقوق بالنظر الى
العلاقات العميقه والوثيقه بين الصين
وكوريا الشماليه بالرغم من ذلك انضمت
الصين الى دول اخرى من مجلس الامن الدولي
في فرد عقوبات قاسيه وصارم على كوريا
الشماليه
حظر الواقع
الصين ليس لديها اي مصالح في جعل هذا شبه
الجزيره مليئه بالسلاح النوويه كلنا نريد
خفض التصعيد وندعو الى استخدام الوسائل
المنطقيه لكي نفهم الاسباب وراء سعي كوريا
الشماليه الى برنامج النووي وفي محاوله
لتهدئه الوضع في شبه الجزيره لتصل الى حل
سلمي لا يمكننا ان ننظر الى البرنامج
كوريا الشماليه النووي
بمعزل عن اي شيء اخر كما لو انه موجود لا
هو مرتبط ارتباطا وثيقا بالحقيقه على
الارض يجب ان نقارنا
قوى القوات بين اليابان والولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه من جهه وكوريا الشماليه
اعتقد ان هذا البرنامج النووي ما هو سوى
مؤشر واحد الاعراض التي يجب ان يركز عليها
وليس الظاهره بحد ذاتها هو يعكس القلق
الشديد الذي تشعر به كوريا الشماليه بشان
استمراريهتها بشان استداماتها سلامه
اراضيها ووحدتها كل ذلك لا يمكن ان يعالج
بما يكفي بدون دفلوماسيه فقط من خلال
زياده التهديد ضد طرف الاخر حين ذلك انت
تجبر كوريا الشماليه على التطوير برنامجها
وعلى سير في مسار اخطر بعد وتعزيز بنات
نووي هذا ما قد يؤدي وسيؤدي الى المزيد من
التصعيد الى المزيد من التوتر ما يؤثر على
كافه الصين خافضه هو الحل الوحيد
الدبلوماسيه من ضمن مناطق هذه الدبلوماسيه
هو مجلس الامن الدولي وكما هنالك خلاف
الان بين ضيفين هنالك ايضا انقسام في مجلس
الامن حاله دون اتخاذ قرار بشان التوترات
المتزايده في شبه الجزيره الكوريه حيث
اخفق اعضاء المجلس في الاتفاق على بيان
المشترك بشان هذه القضيه وفي غياب هذا
التوافق دان عدد من الدول بين الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا بشكل منفصل
التجارب الصاروخيه
بينما دانت الصين التدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه وقالت انها تغذي دوامه التصعيد
في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
المندوبه الامريكيه في مجلس الامن لمحات
الى دور الصين وروسيا في ما سمته فيرهما
غطاءا وحمايه دبلوماسيه لكوريا الشماليه
ايهاب
لقد فعل هذان العدوان كل ما في وسعهما
لتبرير انتهاكات كوريا الشماليه المتكرره
وهما بدورهما مكان كوريا الشماليه من
الاستهزاء بهذا المجلس لقد سمعنا مزعم
هذين العضوين في المجلس بان الولايات
المتحده وكوريا
من خلال التدريبات العسكريه لكن هذا مجرد
وتكرار للدعايه الكوريه الشماليه وهي
روايه مضلله
هذا راي مندوب الامريكيه في مجلس الامن
عود الى ضيفيه واعود الى واشنطن وماثيو
اوكرانيك يعني المقاربه الامريكيه في
موضوع كوريا الشماليه هي في الحقيقه ليست
حتى محل اجماع بين حلفاء الولايات المتحده
كليابان كوريا الجنوبيه سبق وانا اعترض
اعترضت كوريا الجنوبيه على التصعيد في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه من خطاب التصعيد ايام
الرئيس السابق دولار ترامب يعني ليست
المقاربه واحده اصلا حتى يكون هنالك
مقاربه واحده في مجلس الامن
انا الامور بطريقه مختلفه اعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده واحده
مقربه دائما بالنسبه الى كوريا الجنوبيه
فانا امنها امر يهمه واشنطاليه
ترامب جعلت من كوريا الجنوبيه
مالي كوريا الشماليه
شوز
دعم الصين لها هو انها تريد استمرار
الرئيس الكوري في منصبه تخشى انه اذا
نهارا النظام قد تتوحد كوريا وتصير
ديمقراطيه تتحالف مع الولايات المتحده
وتعتبر الصين ان ذلك يشكل تهديدا لها حتى
انا
ساهمت فرديه
خفيفه رفضت فرض عقوبات صارمه وقاسيه لانها
من وجهه نظر الصين وجود هذه الدوله التي
يمكنها ان همم
تفصل بين الصين وكوريا الشماليه يبقى اقصى
كوريا الجنوبيه يبقى افضل من ان تكون
الدوله قويه وبالتالي هي ليست مستعده
لحملي كم يوم يكون على تغيير طريقه عمله
وهنا لك اتهامات مباشره وغير مباشر للصين
السيد فيكتور جاو بانه وراء كل ذلك هي
الحاضر الغائب في ما يحدث في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه هي التي تصاعد حينما تريد وهي
التي تدعو الى خفض التصعيد حينما تريد
كيف تدير الصين هذه
المشكله هذه الازمه
المنطقه امر غير مقبول يجب الا ننسى ان
الوضع الحالي بما فيه همم انفصال
الكوريتين في شبه الجزيره الكوريه هو
نتيجه مباشره
للهدن التي تم توقيعها في العام 30 53 حيث
تنضم الصينيون الى الحرب في كوريا
ليصدى
لشوشه الامريكيه هذا هو الواقع الصين لن
تسمح يوما
بانفصال او بالاحرى انهيار الحكومه
الكوريا الشماليه ولا تسمح لي اي دوله بان
تقوم بتصرف بطريقه احاديه لاسقات النظام
هذا هو الواقع هذا ليس امرا شديدا وهذا
التزام الحكومه الصينيه منذ العام 53
هذا التزام الحكومه منذ عام 53 وهذه مصلحه
الصينيه كما تقول لكن ما هي خيارات
الاداره الامريكيه اعود بالسواري الى ضيفي
من واشنطن سريعا ما هي خيارات اداره
هذا الموقف الصيني واذا عاد بالحسم في
مجلس الامن
خيارات ايجابيه ولكنني اعتبر ان
استراتيجيه الضغط وكذلك اتفاعل هذا
الاستراتيجيه بماسيرين مفيده يمكن ان
نمارس الضغط عسكريا واننيا على كوريا
الشماليه اذا استمرت في هذا المسار ولكن
ايضا هناك خيار واحتمال التفاعل والحوار
مناقشه حدود هذا البرنامج النوويه اذا
وافقت كوريا الشماليه على الطاولات
مفاوضات بالنسبه الى روسيا والصين
وتغطياتهما كوريا الشماليه احدى الحياه او
احد الخيرات هو المدينه العقوبات
امريكيه على مؤسسات مصرفيه وشركات صينيه
تتعامل مع كوريا الشماليه
المؤسسات والمصارف على قطع علاقاتها
وارتباطتها بكوريا الشماليه وزياده الضغط
بالرغمي مما تفضله الحكومه الصينيه
شكرا جزيلا لك ماسي كرونك من
واشنطن المستشار السابق في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه
واشكر ضيفنا من بيجين فيكتور جاو رئيس
الجمعيه الصينيه للدراسات الدوليه
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر في امان الله
[موسيقى]